Trascrizione: Sonia Emanuela Lombardo
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quando sono stata invitata
a venire qui, questa sera,
a parte la gioia iniziale,
la prima cosa che ho pensato è stato:
"E ora cosa mi metto"?
Una cosa normale, diciamo:
ci piace che ogni giorno speciale
sia accompagnato, anche,
da qualcosa di speciale da indossare.
Fosse stata mia madre, mia nonna,
non avrebbero avuto dubbi:
il vestito della domenica,
quella cosa sacra
che si teneva nell'armadio
e che rappresentava qualcosa
che si metteva soltanto nei giorni unici.
In realtà adesso, invece,
i nostri armadi sono pieni di cose,
tantissime cose che possiamo indossare
ma in realtà si ha, sempre, la sensazione
di non avere niente da mettersi.
E allora compriamo, compriamo...
Per di più siamo anche stimolati, diciamo,
da un marketing della moda
che ci propina sempre
delle nuove cose da desiderare.
Ci sembra sempre ci sia qualcosa
che dovremmo effettivamente acquistare.
Allo stesso tempo,
la qualità di quello che acquistiamo
va via via sempre più diminuendo,
anche perché noi non siamo
più capaci, più di tanto,
di valorizzare quella qualità
e di capire dove sta davvero la qualità.
Alla fine ci basta,
una cosa che acquistiamo,
tenerla una stagione nell'armadio;
poi insomma, va bene,
ce ne possiamo anche liberare.
Questa, secondo un'indagine
della Commissione europea,
ogni cittadino europeo consuma mediamente
26 kg di prodotti tessili l'anno.
Fate una moltiplicazione per quanti siamo,
e vi rendete conto
che l'impatto è veramente grosso.
Ci sono poi anche tanti studi
che ci dicono come e quanto
vengono indossati questi capi,
e come li manteniamo.
Vi voglio fare una sintesi veloce:
consumiamo troppo, ecco,
questo è poco ma sicuro.
Poi, ogni tanto, ci facciamo prendere
dal desiderio di fare ordine.
Allora apriamo il nostro armadio,
e ci liberiamo di tutte quelle cose
che o non ci stanno più bene,
o non rappresentano più il nostro stile,
o semplicemente ci hanno annoiato;
magari le doniamo a un'amica,
ma più spesso le possiamo donare
a un'organizzazione benefica,
così ci sentiamo
anche meglio con noi stessi
perché diamo una seconda
possibilità a questo abito
e magari può essere utile
a qualcuno che è meno fortunato di noi.
Ecco: quando questo ciclo si chiude,
quando effettivamente questo circolo
virtuoso riesce a compiersi,
è una cosa positiva.
Però vi voglio dare questa notizia:
in tanti casi, quei capi che doniamo
non hanno questo destino,
perché magari noi -
ci sembrano messi bene,
ma poi in realtà devono essere
aggiustati, lavati e sistemati.
E il valore che potrebbero avere
alla fine
non vale, ecco,
la reimmissione sul mercato.
E quindi, cosa succede a questi capi?
Nella maggioranza dei casi, sono rifiuti.
Dei 26 kg di cui vi ho parlato prima,
di tessuti prodotti ogni anno,
11 kg finiscono in discarica,
e sono una quantità enorme.
Quando vi dico che finiscono in discarica,
significa che non vengono
riusati, né riciclati;
semplicemente, vengono
inceneriti alla fine.
Il tema del riuso è un tema interessante:
quando un capo non può essere usato,
la prima cosa che ci viene in mente
è che un capo possa essere riciclato.
Ma in realtà, il riciclo
è pieno di ostacoli.
E perché?
Ad esempio, i nostri abiti
non sono progettati per essere riciclati,
per tanti motivi.
Innanzitutto, per poter
essere fatto un riciclo decente,
l'abito dovrebbe essere monofibra;
ma la monofibra, magari,
non ci piace tanto,
perché quel mix di fibre
è anche quello poi che dà
un po' di performance al capo,
che quindi ci risulta più interessante.
Poi, se un capo è troppo complicato,
si compone di troppi pezzi
che devono essere smontati,
anche lì lo smontaggio
alla fine non vale la pena,
e quindi poi è di nuovo un rifiuto;
oppure, magari, il capo
ha subito dei trattamenti;
e questi trattamenti, poi,
in fase di riciclo ostacolano,
appunto, il riciclo,
e quindi non possono
essere riciclati.
Sono tantissime le motivazioni
che ostacolano il riciclo;
e vi posso anche dire
che sono tantissime le aziende
che stanno lavorando,
adesso, su questo tema,
che è il tema del momento.
Soprattutto, è il tema del momento
garantire un riciclo
che sia veramente virtuoso;
ed è virtuoso un riciclo
che si può fare da tessuto a tessuto,
da abito vecchio a abito nuovo.
Gli altri tipi di riciclo,
che prevedono il riciclo meccanico
con cui si fanno dei mix di fibre
che poi diventano magari imbottiture,
o vengono utilizzati in edilizia,
sono delle esperienze interessantissime,
ma non possono essere una soluzione
al sovraconsumo che stiamo creando;
abbiamo bisogno che il valore
di quel tessuto rimanga intatto.
In questa indagine "Textile Exchange"
vi mostro quali sono le fibre
più utilizzate al mondo,
e vedete che le fibre sintetiche
la fanno un po' da padrone.
Ecco, solo lo 0,5% di queste fibre
sono riciclate da tessuto a tessuto,
come vi stavo dicendo prima.
Quindi, come capite bene,
le opportunità sono veramente tantissime,
e c'è anche veramente molto da lavorare.
Ma dove finiscono gli abiti
che poi, alla fine, noi non indossiamo?
Quegli abiti finiscono
in Africa, in moltissimi casi:
l'Africa è diventata un po' la discarica
degli abiti usati del mondo,
che noi gentili occidentali
mandiamo in questi paesi.
E qua che fine fanno questi abiti?
In parte, diciamo, alimentano
delle filiere del "second hand" locale
con dei mercati locali
dove vengono vendute;
però in in gran parte, in realtà,
questi capi vengono inceneriti.
Gli abiti sono dappertutto, in Africa:
sono sulle spiagge, nelle discariche,
sono in terra, sul suolo.
Insomma, rappresentano un problema enorme.
In Ghana, ad esempio, c'è Kantamanto,
che è la discarica di abiti usati
più grande al mondo,
e dove praticamente ci sono
dei commercianti locali
che comprano queste balle di stracci
per portarle al mercato.
Non sanno quello che troveranno dentro.
Prima abbiamo detto che la qualità
dei nostri capi sta diminuendo;
e loro lo sperimentano su sé stessi
e sperano, quando aprono la balla,
di essere fortunati
e trovare cose utili per fare
la giornata, per guadagnarsela.
Non sempre è detto che ci riescano.
Ci sono dei paesi africani
in cui il problema dei rifiuti tessili
è diventato così grave
che hanno deciso di chiudere le frontiere
all'importazione degli abiti usati,
facendosi anche carico dei pesantissimi,
diciamo, ricatti poi commerciali
che ricevono dai paesi occidentali,
che in molti casi hanno bloccato
l'esportazione dei loro prodotti.
Ma la sfida c'è, tante organizzazioni
in Africa adesso stanno lavorando
per creare un'economia
circolare in Africa,
cioè per creare competenze
che permettano di prendere questi rifiuti,
di fare i processi di upcycling,
di coinvolgere la comunità creativa
che ne rifà qualcosa;
e anche un'industria, perché no,
che poi sia in grado di riciclare.
È possibile?
Io vengo da Prato,
l'avrete capito dall'accento,
a Prato si ricicla da 150 anni,
si ricicla la lana da 150 anni.
E qui quella magia si fa,
cioè da abito usato a abito nuovo:
è un'esperienza alla fine straordinaria.
Succede grazie a persone
come questo signore,
grazie ai cienciaioli, che sono persone
che nelle mani e negli occhi
hanno una grandissima competenza
che gli permette di riconoscere,
al tatto, le fibre.
Soprattutto queste fibre poi vengono
anche selezionate per colore.
Di tutta questa esperienza
vi parlo, anche,
in un documentario
che si chiama "Stracci",
che ha la regia di Tommaso Santi
e che ho realizzato insieme a lui
e spero che avrete, in qualche modo,
l'occasione di vederlo.
Praticamente, come vi dicevo prima,
Il futuro quindi si compone, anche,
di quelli che sono
i comportamenti che noi avremo
e di come saremo capaci, poi,
di relazionarci anche
con il nostro armadio.
Può sembrare incredibile,
ma è una cosa che coinvolge tutti noi.
Ognuno deve prendersi
le proprie responsabilità:
i governi, che devono fare
una normativa chiara,
che praticamente metta dei paletti chiari
su quello che si può fare in questi casi,
e che quindi stabiliscano, anche,
la responsabilità del produttore;
i brand, che devono imparare a fare
una progettazione del capo
perché un capo duri a lungo;
e poi noi, che dobbiamo assolutamente
far durare più a lungo i nostri capi.
Scrivere la parola fine
sulla vita dei nostri capi
il più a lungo possibile,
imparare a ripararli,
a ripensarli, a ricucirli:
rimettiamoci a rammendare!
Questa è la vera sfida,
ed è la cosa più importante.
Dobbiamo amare, alla fine,
quello che è nel nostro armadio.
Dobbiamo riscoprire anche certi valori:
e perché no, anche riscoprire
il vestito della domenica
che può essere anche di buon augurio
per farci avere tante giornate speciali.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)